hello and welcome to this video playing
Hyundai law I had recently a gambit I
play the game but I think recently
against me and now he we have a wasn't
that the gambit yeah that was the gambit
and so now when he goes for a main line
Petrov
hmm thinking there's a bit odd kind of
the most normal position heaven Yahoo p1
is one of the one of the main
continuations so it's tough to remember
all those lines we should have five I
think
we against Quincy - you almost always go
with a knight to e6
[Music]
I don't quite remember how it continues
from here I only recently analyzed said
of course but it's it's so much stuff
okay I mean I don't think this can be
worse from like look we made a huge pot
of tea for tonight
and it's it's it's really really heavy
okay yeah he's only for a lot I was
thinking maybe I should have played
Bishop g6 that certainly was an idea I
take on c3 now I have to reckon with
Bishop takes f5 yeah I probably made a
move order misstep there I kind of have
to do it at home so it is really not
what I wanted Bishop takes at five it's
just problem
yeah
yeah there was a that was an opening bit
of an opening disaster him completely
forgot how this line is played Jeremy so
I lost the pawn pretty awful
and he's quite close with consolidating
his position ever just overnight f3
Bishop III is just going to be a pawn up
for pretty much nothing yeah I probably
have to go Bishop g6 them you know
instead of instead of my continuation
okay before is a bit strange I'm not
sure that you need that you need the
smooth
I mean why it is not really well
developed okay so I'm getting the d5
square
well that is things are improving a
little bit White's extra pawn is
currently not playing a significant role
which means that is what I'm trying to
say is it is not unimportant that he is
a pawn up but it is often a very
important thing to check if the pawn
that you are down if that is actually
doing something useful for the opponent
or not and currently you could question
that yeah it's got the default pawn that
it is not moving and I have a really
nice night coming to d5 he also has this
pretty awful bishop okay I have to watch
our toward the back rank of this limb
that is a good tempo
yeah wonder age six or what is the what
is the approach I might as well go g6
the bishop on a1 it's not coming to age
six anytime soon I'm not really worried
Jim I don't think that I'm substantially
worse anymore
just wonder if I'm just staying active
I'm not going to be worse just not going
to happen he can check me and maybe a
check the pawn that is certainly
possible so let's get out of a possible
check
[Music]
I mean that's just it's difficult it's
difficult for me to make any headway as
the problem will take care and probably
play and create I know that looks a
little bit passive but I'm not saying
I'm not seeing what my queen is doing on
d1 if it is any better
he wants to go Bishop g5 and that that I
should not just allow training
it's this is just going to be a draw I
think oops not to draw that was strange
but yeah suddenly gave me the bishop
yeah I mean I miss played the opening
and was a pawn down I don't think it was
easy to convert yeah I think I made a
mistake here after is-3 I probably have
to play Bishop g6 cm should chief I
don't quite remember
I would really need to look it up
there's so many lines that I've studied
recently in this opening bishop g6
however looks very very okay protecting
this and just be ready to capture him
any piece coming this is probably
probably not as good even though the
engine claims that just h6 is good why
isn't that just winning stuff take take
Queen to e7 oh okay it should be five
I see yeah so what I did was just bad
him so just upon down for nothing but I
think I think here why it should not go
before it's just helping me a little bit
if he just goes in I have three Bishop
III just like developed normally think
you have better chances to convert after
before I have a five and now man
whatever you do you don't want to do you
don't want to play c5 what you did
taking maybe taking but general that
didn't help and I think after c5 I think
the worst problems that I have are over
the pawn on d4 is not going anywhere and
it's is difficult to convert maybe what
I did to him invading with the Queen
doesn't even all that great i later
recognized that and were threatening
much and white has made a bit of
progress here you know like you mean why
this just just more comfortable but it's
so difficult so difficult to get any
thought of conversion yeah and him
Knight f6 given by the engine because of
Queen 82 ideas yeah I thought this is a
simple solution going for a blockade on
the light squares after Queen takes and
King f7 I think it's equal it's
basically a fortress I'm just sitting
here and the bishop is not able to take
any of my pawns I mean it is relatively
easy to establish that it's a fortress
if he goes g4
I'm just staying I'm not taking and this
means that you can at best capture on a5
or h5 so a pawn will always cover g4 f4
is covered by the night this is covered
by the
one you can go to default with the king
I don't mind there and I'm just flipping
between ecigs and f7 it's a total draw
yeah an optimist could argue that black
could maybe even one of the problems
it'd be better but it's not help not
happening really yeah me plate B should
be three this is something I'll slip I
guess just the mouse mouse issue and
okay I just I just take it I think it's
it's basically a clean draw yeah as I
mentioned I have this fortress and
Dwight um yeah so we're not much I can
go to d5 mmm yeah yeah you cannot
construct any sort of winning idea for
Beck I think okay guys thanks for
watching